you're watching white here's what we got
for you this week ad blocking on your
phone is popular but is it fair we speak
to the expert to find out I meet
Wikipedia co-founder Jimmy Wales who
tells me how some governments are being
naive and we've got American thought
simulators covered with touchdowns and
slam dunks are plenty in our games
review hello from ipx poke one of
Europe's biggest IT of us the reason
we're here is to interview one of text
most successful entrepreneur but before
we get to that we want to tell you about
a little issue we've been discussing in
the swype user of late you know those
online adverts that's pop up when you're
browsing look like them or not they're
actually paying for the content you're
looking at but now a recent move my
apple means that you can install and
blockers on your cloak so the question
is a block or matzo ball
here's to we all know the situation
you're trying to read or watch something
interesting online and it's right there
you can't see it because of all the
adverts you've been able to block popup
ads on your desktop computer for a while
but now Apple is allowing developers to
publish software that stops them on your
phone too we wanted to build a tool that
enables users to have the choice and
choose what happens on on their devices
and then on their browsers on in this
case it is it is the debate of a
blocking but in general what he believed
that the user should always have control
over how they consume the content and
how how they use their devices this kind
of software is proving popular in the UK
around 12 million of us are actively
blocking adverts each month Apple's
decision to allow ad blockers only
affects mobile web browsers like Safari
so not the apps on your phone but the
change has triggered a debate over
paying for content we have to help
people appreciate that what they receive
for free costs money to produce if you
strangulate the ability for people to
make money in return for content
production they simply won't make
content one developer even pulled his
chart-topping advert blocking app after
just two days saying it just doesn't
feel good he says this is a kind of war
with consumers on one side and
advertisers on the other adverts have
become a problem they've stopped people
being able to read the content they've
stopped people being able to look at the
sites that they love so I think what
this is is a wake-up call for the
industry that we we have to change we
have to be a little bit more gentle with
the way that we advertise and we have to
make sure that actually we're putting
the user first some publishers are being
proactive and trying to make changes to
advertising that suit their users aunty
adblock company page fair helps websites
create what are called non intrusive
adverts what we need are ads that don't
snoop on your data that don't slow your
computer that don't jump around the
screen we need adds that respect the
user and support the publisher
advertising 2 point 0 must be better the
trick will be to
to compromise that makes everyone happy
Stewart Duggan Sky News you're watching
like coming up why Wikipedia co-founder
Jimmy Wales think some governments don't
understand technology the first it's a
roundup of some of this week other
techniques what's been described as the
world's first completely wireless phone
charger has begun crowdfunding on
IndieGoGo wall jacks is apparently
compatible with almost any handset that
sits on it the developers trying to
raise money to cover production costs a
group of scientists from Israel have
become the first team to sign a contract
in the race to land a rover on the moon
if successful space il will be the first
privately-funded company to reach the
moon and win 30 million dollars as part
of Google's Lunar XPrize competition
Twitter's launched a new feature that
showcases the top things being talked
about on the site regardless of who you
follow moments has only launched in the
US for now and can be found by tapping
on a lightning bolt icon a device that
lets you see who's at your front door
from anywhere in the world has won a
hundred thousand pounds of funding and
the contract to sell in a major
department store people which uses a
smart camera has won jlab John Lewis's
startup incubator competition now the
big-name speaker who opened this year's
Expo with none other than Jimmy Wales
the web entrepreneur and the man best
known for being co founder of wikipedia
he was once named one of the 100 most
influential people in the world so we
thought he's a pretty good person to
speak to about that ad blocking debate
and a few other things
so if the ads that people are doing our
intrusive and annoying then it tends to
push people to install ad blocking
software but if the ads are relevant and
not too annoying and show up at a time
when they make sense then people won't
block them and so I'm not worried about
some apocalyptic decline of heads forty
websites because everybody blocks the
ads I just don't think that's likely to
happen
I always recommend to people assume that
anything that you put into digital
format is vulnerable even if it's a text
or what's that message yeah i mean just
assume just it's the safest thing to do
it's sort of like it's it's excessive
but it's sort of like I have an
assumption that if I see a mushroom
growing in the wild it's probably going
to kill me if I eat it not completely
true but I don't have the expertise to
know
do you think the government is quite
naive when it comes to encryption and
security I see government's not
understanding technology very well and
so they assume there are policy options
on the table which don't exist and you
know to say ban in to end encryption is
like saying well it's bad math because
it's very straightforward mathematics
the software is already out there freely
shared online you know it's you can't
ban it it's just not going to happen so
that's not a policy option so anybody
who proposes that is Polly's option you
immediately know Oh actually you don't
know anything about technology look you
have no idea what you're talking about
so what kind of government do because
they you know they need to be able to
spy on potential terrorists well I mean
there are things they can do good
old-fashioned police work you know not
it sort of the world hasn't changed as
much as they would like us to think they
have the bad guys have always managed to
talk to each other in private you know
when you know go for go for a walk in
Hyde Park and have a private
conversation and that's always been
possible and always will be and as we
have different levels of security online
the bad guys will always gravitate to
secure technologies and it just means
that as of just a fact of reality just
as the police can't know what you say in
your living room at home to your friend
they can't know what you say just
because your friends across town and
you've texted using a C or chat app so
it's overblown the need for this is ben
much overblown you can watch the rest of
my interview with jimmy wales on Sky
News calm and on our apps but now it's
time for our games review and this week
we've got American sports crazy with an
NBA and an NFL game and if sports titles
aren't your thing we've got one game
featuring han Solo iron man and Mickey
Mouse yeah I was surprised to hear steve
madden NFL 16 is obviously the latest
installment of EA Sports American
football franchise and it's one of my
favorite games of the year so far the
spectacle of the whole thing is just
incredibly in the way that only a mirror
sports can do the commentary also
absolutely pitch perfect and the
gameplay which of course is the most
important thing is splendid they
actually use a sort of QuickTime events
for the passing obviously QTEs quite a
bad reputation in gaming but it's not
QTEs in the press X to go to next
cutscene actually the way that you press
the buttons like even whether you tap or
hold and the timing of that when you get
these on-screen prompts has a direct
impact on the outcome of the game so
it's not boring qts they all have a
direct impact on the outcome and a match
whether you like American football or
even sport at all as a video game this
is still definitely one worth checking
out 16 Disney infinity 3.0 is the latest
installment obviously in the disney
infinity franchise from disney and
lucasarts and this time they're really
focusing on the star wars franchise
obvious that's very timely because we
got the movie coming out at the end of
the year and now that Disney have got
the rights there they're squeezing every
last drop they can out of Star Wars it's
part of this increasing range of titles
that we're seeing on the market known as
toys to life things like Nintendo's
amiibo you've got activision skylanders
and most recently lego dimensions where
you have to purchase these little
figurines to unlock additional content
in the game so putting all that to one
side the big question obviously is is
the game any good and it is but whether
or not you're going to feel you've got
value for money probably depends on how
much you enjoy collecting those little
figurines but also how much you want to
dive into the creative tools that are a
big part of the game because the story
missions themselves aren't actually that
long but the combat in fairness very
very good thanks to ninja theory's
involvement the geyser didn't slave
Devil May Cry those games so the
gameplay is good but it's not that much
of it in the story missions themselves
essentially if your kids love Disney or
Star Wars they're going to love it but
your wallet is probably going to wish
that they did
NBA 2k16 is the latest installment in
very long reign franchiser basketball
games from 2k it looks absolutely great
and although that doesn't affect the
gameplay which incidentally is great
there's all this lovely detail in the
visuals in the game that you don't
necessarily get with a lot of other
sports games sports games come tend to
be just generic walls of crowds with 10
different animation somewhere but in NBA
2k16 we've got like the photographer's
at one end and they're all individual
people doing their own thing you've got
the front row where people might be
having a conversation talking to their
friends or watching the match or every
individual person is an individual
character and they're animated and no
that doesn't make the game more fun but
it creates such a rich world is so much
more satisfying and immersive to feel
that you're in a genuine environment and
that's quite unusual this doesn't really
have that many tutorials so if you're
not familiar with the game could be
quite hard to get into but still another
great game in a very successful long
series that's it for this week take a
look at Sky News on mobile and iPad for
some more tech news I'll be back next
week for life
you